al'approche du réveillon nous vous
proposons de découvrir quelques
commerçants locaux et des idées pour vos
repas de fin d'année et oui on va aller
découvrir deux boutiques différentes moi
je vais me rendre vienne bibard à
maurepas entre vins champagne ou encore
bière je pense qu'on va avoir plusieurs
choses à découvrir et à découvrir et
consommer avec modération bien sûr et
vous justin je crois qu'on va vous
retrouver au rayon fromage si c'est bien
ça exactement céline et j'y vais de ce
pas
[Musique]
je me trouve à la fromagerie les petites
souris à montigny le bretonneux et je
suis accompagné de muriel diri vous êtes
la fromagère bon jour en jour donc vous
vous avez créé la boutique un peu pour
faire redécouvrir un autre patrimoine
français qu'est le fromage et vous
sélectionnez vos produits auprès de
petits producteurs c'est bien ça j'ai
créé ma boutique il y a deux ans avant
le confinement je sélectionne donc mes
fromages auprès de petits producteurs
avec qui je suis en collaboration toutes
les semaines pour sélectionner les
fromages les meilleures sélections tout
ce qui est à la truffe ont décru ces
biens superbe est-ce que déjà pouvez
nous parler un peu vos produits phares
alors les produits phares pour les fêtes
on a rentré du coup au mois d'octobre
une tomme de brebis au lait cru ou celui
ci c'est ça qui a affiné nom du foie
dans les pyrénées donc ce qui donne au
goût de les brebis et un doigt seydoux
d'accord on a également le parisien
truffé existe aussi au lait cru mais que
je continue mais que je ne suis pas son
truc et après ça on a le délice de
vulcain qui ressemble à vulcain par
rapport aux volcans puisqu'il vient de
l'allier et celui ci est un chef passe
et crémeux à s'étendre très bien
peut-être est-ce que l'on peut goûter un
peu tout ça ça m'a donné on peut y a pas
de souci respect je me suis alors
donc on a un aux trois fromages comment
va se passer la dégustation alors pour
une dégustation généralement commence du
moins fort au plus fort d'accord on va
commencer par le délice de vulcain allez
je vous laisse déguster donc là ils sont
un petit peu près parce qu'il vient de
sortir du frigo qui permet dans le démon
basque
ferfay
c'est encore un petit peu froid parce
qu'il sort du frigo normalement pour les
sortir une heure avant pour la
dégustation d'accord un site où on va
avoir du coup la tonne qui a fini dans
du fond donc c'est normal qu'elle ait un
peu de foin dessus puisqu'elle est
vraiment enroulé dans le foie d'accord
on le laisse de succès pour la
présentation fait de l'aidc dessus de la
croûte se mange donc une croûte
naturelle après ça on boira de la fois
pour manger bien sûr ne mange pas le
point évident
donc la croûte se mange c'est ça
mais ce superbe où ça c'est d'où leur
magot ouais c'est vrai par après c'est
vraiment il a eu la médaille d'or au
mondial des fromages aux retraités
d'accord bah voila je suis super qualité
on va voir le parisien truffe et
donc la récente et bien le truc c'est
pour ça qu'on les emballe dans l'est
dans la vitrine pour pas qu'ils se
parfaire oui à sa sur la truffe
c'est puissant allez je vous de ça
[Musique]
vous êtes sur un triple prennent parfois
enrichi entraîne donc un peu plus
caloriques
je crois que c'est mon pépé
il est super bon après on n'a pas
l'habitude de manger forcément des idées
propagées à la truffe comme ça non pour
relever la passe à ceux qui aiment pas
trop relevé on a de la truffe d'été qui
est moins forte on a de la thriller pour
ceux qui aiment vraiment la trouille qui
compte vraiment la saveur du fromage on
a de tout et écouter notre dégustation
est terminée moi je vais quand même
finir mon fromage merci beaucoup en tout
cas variable mérite de nous avoir reçus
donc voila moi je pense que j'ai trouvé
mon fromage à pour la parrainer et puis
céline j'imagine que vous aussi vous
avez à des propositions à vous faire
pour cette fin d'année en tout cas pour
les repas effectivement justin je pense
vous trouvez quelque chose de sympa je
me trouve ovi nbi barre à maurepas
aujourd'hui avec son gérant éric bibal
c'est ça bonjour bonjour et bienvenue
aux bienne be est-ce que vous pouvez
nous présenter un petit peu le concept
du coup dans cet endroit bien sûr donc
on est un concept de
deux caves vente à emporter
au vent des besoins de la bière des
spiritueux et on a une partie bar
événementiel et donc je sais que vous
faites bières vins champagne c'est un
peu difficile de s'y retrouver des fois
est-ce que vous pouvez nous proposer une
petite sélection de vins pour le nouvel
an parce que là la soirée aviv et je
crois que beaucoup de personnes voudront
savoir ce que vous nous avez préparé
pour commencer je vous ai proposé un jeu
vous propose un chardonnay vins blancs
en cépage chardonnay blanc très très
fruité très beurré vraiment d'une grande
finesse ça va très bien se marier avec
une entrée
un poisson ça va devoir également un
apéritif on peut pas faire non plus fêté
fêter la fin d'année de sans boire une
coupe de champagne évidemment donc j'ai
sélectionné un champagne de pour péter
le charme meyreuil un blanc de noir un
champagne brut mais c'est avec une
certaine de sucrosité c'est vraiment
très fin aussi donc idéal pour fêter
fêter la fin d'année avec ça eh ben je
crois qu'avec ça on est pas trop mal et
moi par contre j'aime beaucoup le foie
gras alors ce que vous auriez des
conseils pour une bonne boisson qui peut
accompagner le foie gras j'ai fait une
sélection de 2,20
légèrement sucré notamment un jurançon
qui est un vin de
une appellation des pyrénées si on
n'aime pas forcément les vins trop
sucrés on peut aussi manger un foie gras
avec un vin d'alsace un divorce très
mineures moi ça m'a donné envie de
goûter je sais pas vous mais en tout cas
on va passer à la dégustation avec
plaisir donc là je vois les deux
bouteilles dont vous m'avez parlé tout à
l'heure de vin parfaitement adapté pour
le servir avec un foie gras ben je vous
proposais le déguster un bon vin goûté
ça tout de suite allez je vais tomber
dans de masques
[Musique]
celle ci
il est celui des sucres et là on est
vraiment dans côté boulot lynch ont fait
ce que vous voulez dire avec le fois
gras mon avis ça va parfaitement
convenir ça me fait penser un peu à la
confiture con mais avec le foie gras des
fois oui il ya ce côté un peu compotée
sa voix la confiture effectivement ça
sophie très bien et confiture de figues
avec du foie gras fait parfait et le
deuxième du coup c'est vous m'avez dit
que c'est un vin pour wanda siens
cépages donc le sais pas chez les
raisins qui utilisera plus fort en nous
la foi oui un petit peu plus marqué en
moins - le côté sucré
donc les gloss traminer cd20 très fruité
avec des notes un peu de fruits jaunes
ont été très vifs d'accord très
aromatique voilà ça permet d'avoir un
côté très très acidulé également avec un
foie gras sans avoir le côté sucré trop
marquée c'est parfait c'est les vins
d'alsace sont les bois toujours ou un
moment à cette période de fêtes ce que
vous avez un petit conseil pour savoir
comment reconnaître un bon un bon vin ce
que je conseille surtout au moment de
choisir à 20 c'est de regarder millésime
en fonction des régions il ya des vins
qui peuvent se garder d'autres moins
longtemps
voilà des années qu'ils sont
intéressantes d'autres moins en tout cas
pour les vins de garde mais toujours
l'importance de se faire conseiller par
son caviste notamment je crois qu'on
préférait sera celui là d'accord écoutez
le choix est fait pour pour le réveillon
celui ci pourra merci nous avons réussi
merci à vous avec grand plaisir et à
très bientôt bienne be en tout cas
justin nous voilà bien équipé pour le
nouvel an quand à vous on espère vous
avoir donné quelques idées en attendant
passer de bonnes fêtes